THE EXCITEMENT THAT THAT ACCUSE
OTHERS OF IS WHAT THEY
THEMSELVES PRACTICE.
JOINING ME NOW IS CARRIE
SEVERINO, A FORMER SECURITY
CLERK AND MIKE DAVIS.
MIKE, LET'S START WITH YOU.
WE ALL KNOW WHAT IS HAPPENING
HERE.
WE KNOW THAT THIS LEAK WAS DONE
WITH A PURPOSE.
EVEN THREATS OF JUSTICES,
THEY'RE TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
WALK US THROUGH WHAT MAY BE
HAPPENING IN LAYMEN TERMS, IF
YOU COULD?
>> YEAH, IF YOU'RE MAKING
THREATS AGAINST SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES, YOU'RE VIOLATING
FEDERAL LAW.
THERE'S LAWS IN THE BOOKS FOR
ASSAULTS, FOR THREATS, FOR
CONSPIRACY, FOR OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
IT IS DISGRACEFUL THAT ATTORNEY
GENERAL MERRICK GARLAND, A
FORMER FEDERAL JUDGE HIMSELF,
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL, LISA
MONACO, CHRIS WRAY, THE U.S.
ATTORNEYS IN D.C., MARYLAND, THE
EASTERN DISTRICT OF VIRGINIA,
CRICKETS FROM THESE PEOPLE.
THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE.
THESE ARE REAL THREATS AGAINST
THE LIVES OF SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES AND THEY NEED TO STEP
UP RIGHT NOW AND DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THIS.
>> Laura: CARRIE, WE'LL GET TO
WHAT IS HAPPENING ABOUT THE
OPINION.
BUT THAT IS A QUESTION, IS IT
NOT?
WE'RE AT A TIME WHEN WE'VE HAD
60 MONTHS OF DEMOCRATS SCREAMING
INCITEMENT, INCITEMENT AND
INSURRECTION AND NOW JEN PSAKI
IS PARSING HER WORDS ABOUT WHAT
THIS IS, THIS INTIMIDATION
CAMPAIGN, WHICH I'M CALLING
TERRORISTIC BECAUSE I THINK IT
IS ABOUT THE JUSTICES.
DO THEY HAVE ADEQUATE SECURITY
DOVETAILING FROM WHAT MIKE JUST
SAID?
>> I SURE HOPE SO.
I MEAN, I AGREE.
THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
CONCERNING THINGS ABOUT THIS
LEAK.
NOT ONLY DOES IT STRIKE AT A
TRUST IN THE INHERENT WORKINGS
OF THE COURT BUT THIS IS AN
ACTIVE THREAT AGAINST THE
JUSTICES THEMSELVES.
I KNOW THEY'RE RAMPING UP
SECURITY.
THIS IS WHY I THINK A LOT OF
THIS -- LET'S JUST ISSUE THIS
OPINION QUICKLY.
I THINK IT'S NO SURPRISE THOUGH.
JEN PSAKI USED TO WORK FOR
DEMAND JUSTICE.
THE MOST DARK MONEY GROUP OUT
THERE.
THEY'RE PRAISING THE LEAKER.
SAYING WE NEED MORE SUPREME
COURT LOOKS.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT SAID
THE CONSTITUTION IS TRASHED AND
SHOULD BE SCRAPPED.
THEY'RE TRYING TO USE THIS TO
PACK THE COURTS EVEN IF THEY
CAN'T SWITCH THIS DECISION NOW.
OR SOMEONE SAID LET'S PACK IT
BEFORE THE END OF THE TERM.
GOODNESS.
IT'S NO HOLDS BARRED.
IT'S ANY MEANS JUSTIFIED THE END
HERE.
THAT'S WHAT IS SO DISTURBING
ABOUT THIS LEAK AND THE THREATS
THAT WE'RE SEEING.
>> Laura: MIKE, THESE ARE PEOPLE
THAT CLAIM TO BE THREATENED BY
PRO LIFE PEOPLE PRAYING OUTSIDE
ABORTION CLINICS.
SILENTLY PRAYING.
THEY THINK THAT IS A THREAT.
NOW GIVEN WHAT IS HAPPENING,
YEAH, WE RESPECT THE RIGHT TO
PRIVACY.
HERE'S HOW CNN FRAMED THE
THREATS AGAINST THE SUPREME
COURT TODAY.
WATCH.
>> LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS ARE
PREPARING FOR POTENTIAL VIOLENCE
IN THE CAPITOL AND NATIONWIDE.
CAPITOL POLICE ARE WARNING THE
FAR RIGHT IS CALLING FOR
VIOLENCE AGAINST A RELIGIOUS
GROUP.
>> THERE'S A POTENTIAL FOR
STAFF.
>> Laura: THIS ISN'T JOURNALISM.
THIS IS PRO ABORTION PROPAGANDA.
WE'VE HAD PRO LIFE CENTERS
VANDALIZED IN JUST THE LAST 24,
48 HOURS, WHICH HAPPENS
REGULARLY.
NOW THE THREAT IS FROM RIGHT
WING?
NO ONE SHOULD BE THREATENING
ANYONE HERE.
BUT THAT'S THE FRAMING OF THIS?
>> YEAH, IT'S GASLIGHTING.
IT'S LAUGHABLE.
THEY'RE THREATENING CONSERVATIVE
JUSTICES?
THAT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
THEY'RE GETTING THREATS AGAINST
THEIR LIFE ONLINE AND ELSEWHERE
RIGHT NOW.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT NEEDS TO
STEP IT UP, STARTED MAKING
ARRESTS FOR CONSPIRACY, FOR
OBSTRUCTION AND ASSAULT.
>> Laura: CARRIE, I WANT TO READ
A RECENT PASSAGE FROM A WEBSITE
A LOT OF LAWYERS READ.
IT'S CALLED SCOTUS LOG.
THERE WERE AT LEAST TWO LEAKERS
AND THREE LEAKS.
THE FIRST LEAK WAS TO THE "WALL
STREET JOURNAL" EDITORIAL BOARD
LAST WEEK.
THEY SAID THE COURT VOTED TO
OVERRULE ROE.
CHIEF JUSTICEALL-OUT
DOES THAT MAKE ANY SENSE TO YOU
IF THAT IS HAPPENING?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF THERE WAS A
LEAK THERE.
I DON'T THINK YOU WOULD NEED A
LEAK TO COME TO THE CONCLUSION
FOR THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL."
CHIEF JUSTICE IS JUST DESPERATE
TO FIND SOME WAY TO UPHOLD THE
VAN BUT NOT OVERTURN ROE.
WE KNOW THAT IS NOT LEGALLY
POSSIBLE.
BOTH SIDES OF THE ARGUMENT SAID
NO, NO, I'M SORRY YOU CAN'T DO
THAT.
YOU'RE SEEING NOW, HE'S BEING
ATTACKED AND HIS ADDRESS BEING
GIVEN OUT AS ONE OF THESE THAT
OVERTURNED ROE EVEN THOUGH HE'S
NOT TRYING TO DO THAT.
WAS HE TRYING TO LOBBYING THE
JUSTICES?
THAT WOULDN'T SURPRISE ME.
DOES THAT MEAN THEY'RE LIKELY TO
HAVE SWITCHED?
WHY HEARD THEIR ARGUMENTS IN
DECEMBER.
I ACTUALLY WAS VERY ENCOURAGED
BY WHAT I HEARD FROM JUSTICES
KAVANAUGH AND BARRETT.
THEY SEEM TO GET IT.
KAVANAUGH SAID THE COURT SHOULD
REMAIN STRICTLY IMPARTIAL HERE.
NEUTRAL AND THEY WERE NOT GOING
TO BE PRO CHOICE OR PRO LIFE.
JUSTICE BARRETT WAS TALKING
ABILITY TO GIVE CHILDREN UP FOR
ADOPTION.
THIS SHOWS --
>> Laura: WE CAN SEE WHERE
THEY'RE GOING.
I WOULD HOPE ALL THE JUSTICES
COME OUT AND CONDEMN THESE
TERRORISTIC ACTS ON THE PART OF
ACTIVISTS AND SAY THIS WILL NOT
STAND.
THEY NEED TO FIND THIS LEAKER OR
LEAKERS, I SHOULD SAY, OUT OF
THE SUPREME COURT.
THIS CAN'T BE T